pour la situation colombie qui est
suivie par la france plusieurs dizaines
de personnes se sont rassemblées devant
le consulat de colombie à paris cet
après-midi des ressortissants dénonce
les violences subies par les
manifestants après plusieurs heures
d'attentes
ils ont pu transmettre un courrier aux
consuls de colombie en france une lettre
et une section pour démontrer leur
soutien et dénoncer la répression
toutes les semaines il y avait massacre
en colombie tout les masques et les
semaines il y avait mort toujours des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme
c'est un pays où il n'ya pas de garantie
pour la pour les personnes qui veulent
manifester exiger le droit de vivre une
vie digne
alors aujourd'hui on s'est donné rendez
vous ici pour protester pour montrer
qu'on est avec eux qu'ils ne sont pas
seuls et différentes personnes de
différentes parties de droite de gauche
représentants des peuples autochtones
des afro descendants des étudiants des
travailleurs se sont rassemblés
aujourd'hui ici pour dire on est fatigué
on n'en peut plus et pas possible qu'il
y ait autant de violence et autant
d'injustices dans un même territoire
tout la communauté européenne comme les
états unis
il connaît très bien cette situation
mais ils veulent silence avant la
situation colombien c'est pour ça que
l'initiative citoyenne et tous les
colombiens et on évite à l'extérieur
nous sont là ici pour manifester
c'est ta situation qui sont vivre
aujourd'hui en colombie à des
répressions des assassinats des
disparitions de toutes les leaders
civique et dé tous qui a passé dont les
conduites en main d'ouvre dans les
périodes et 70 ans